if Brian's going to win sherita's
respect as a head chef he needs to
become more involved in preparing the
food as well as cooking it number 13
lucky for some
but since his hours were cut he's been
dropped in a catch-22 situation where's
little lady on Brian's been left holding
the baby it became a problem if this
Claire had to go to work yeah and we had
to find a way of meeting the bill at the
end of the month yeah you know and
that's why I can't do Tuesdays and
Wednesdays the whole thing is just
confused yeah you know as Brian's
involvement with the food has diminished
so too has his confidence the first time
he made meatloaf two years ago it was a
disaster so we're gonna prove that Brian
can not only do it but do it better but
you got to be strong now she's gonna
concentrate in you're gonna be running
the kitchen yes you have to be strong
yes yes the problem with sherita's
meatloaf is the bacon no time it's
cooked it's like cutting into leather
baking you saw dries out totally
fascination streaky bacon place one nice
fatty piece of bacon there as it's
cooking yeah it's putting moisture
exactly inside the meatloaf yeah you
know if I put my foot down and said no
this is like this right but I think I
can see myself going farm you know I can
achieve things it's a it's a happy
feeling you know happy feeling
hmm just love them the season is just
right you're not too salty yes honey I
was fine doesn't need her name doesn't
need anything everything else